hi I'm Priyanka today I'm going to share
with you some of the most common
questions used in product management
interviews and what interviewers are
actually looking for in your responses
in my experience as a product leader
I've been on both sides of the interview
process and I'm so excited to share some
tips to help you Ace those interviews
let's dive in one how would you design
an oven for a person in a wheelchair
I suggest a four-step approach for this
type of product design question first
ask clarifying questions and gather
information
for example you can ask does a person
have any disabilities besides being
unable to walk what kind of oven are we
talking about how are they going to be
using this product or oven and so on
second start to Define what specific
problems you want to solve next design
the product features I suggest making a
list on pen and paper and then talking
your interviewer through it so they
understand what is your thought process
and finally prioritize that feature list
that you came up with and share your
decisions around what you prioritize to
build first in your MVP or minimum
viable product and why
two Google is thinking about acquiring
the question and answer site quora
should they acquire it why or why not
with this question the interviewer is
trying to test your product strategy
knowledge
you might Begin by thinking out loud
about the strategy of both the target
company and its potential purchaser what
do these companies fundamentally do are
their missions aligned would the
purchaser gain something from this
acquisition then think through the
customers the competitors and overall
industry Trends as well as your Revenue
generation or monetization plans ask the
interviewer what are goals and success
criteria are for example do we want to
capture a new target market or generate
a new Revenue stream don't forget to
summarize your product strategy based on
all these different considerations and
share the products value proposition
with the interviewer
[Music]
three a
number of videos watched on YouTube per
day
similar to what I talked about for the
product design question earlier I
suggest you take a four-step approach to
answering this type of Market sizing or
estimation question step one always
start by asking clarifying questions to
validate your assumptions remember these
questions are meant to be intentionally
vague for example in this case you could
ask are we calculating the number of
videos watched in North America or just
the US can we assume that we exclude the
videos that are abandoned halfway
and so on next decide whether you will
use a top-down or a bottom-up approach
and share that with the interviewer also
share what is your overall approach or
formula for example in this case it
would be total number of YouTube users
multiplied by videos watched per user
per day estimate this for a few
different types of user segments based
on user behavior and then add up the
total
once you share this approach jump to
step three which is get into the details
and do your estimations you could start
with the U.S population being 300
million and how many of that have
internet and how many out of that watch
YouTube and so on once you have your
answer in step four don't forget to do a
reality check on your answer to make
sure it sounds reasonable
4. give me an example of a time when
your product failed how did you work
with others to figure out what was wrong
and do a second launch
for these types of Behavioral questions
the interviewer is testing a few
different things such as your resilience
your ability to collaborate
cross-functionally with different teams
and your ability to be creative to
impress the interviewer with this
question make sure to give real world
examples from your experience on how you
tackle challenging situations as a
product manager if you had a failed
launch what did you learn from it how
did you motivate your team to Pivot when
the product design or strategy changed
five how do you measure the success of a
product
for this question I suggest you start by
asking what stage of the product life
cycle are we talking about for example
if the product is very mature your
customer acquisition and engagement
metrics might be already strong and you
might want to focus on customer
retention and referral
the r
or pirate metrics framework is also
quite helpful to remember the stages of
the product life cycle
a stands for acquisition then a for
activation
and then retention
referral and Revenue
so it talks about that different stages
in your customer life cycle you might
also want to ask the interviewer what
their success criteria is to align with
them and get clarification for example
you're asked to design the inside of a
self-driving car the interviewer might
tell you that the success criteria is
net promoter score which is a referral
metric and then you can design your
product with that metric in mind
and there you have it I hope that gives
you a good sense of what to expect in a
product management interview and how you
can Ace your responses
[Music]